What's up guys, we are Pongfinity!
Today we're gonna play a match to 11 points
andafter each point we'll make a hole in the table.
Let's go!
It's time to build the table!
Like this.
Well it's starting to look okay.
It's there! It's a table tennis table!
Somebody stand on it. Do the Emil stand test.
We've done it! Emil solid!
I think we can start playing.
Yeah start destroying it!
Okay Emil you ready for the final touch?
Yes the Pongfinity net!
Get yours from Pongfinity.store.
It's timefor the match then!
Yeah so how are we going to play this match?
If you win the point,
When i win the point.
you'll get to drill a hole on your own side.
To make itmore difficult for Otto.
First point without holes.
Sorry Emil!
Now you get to make a hole on your side.
Okay where do i want it.
Let's putit there.
We'll see how this goes.
Okay this is gonna take a while.
Okay that was interesting...
It broke!
Did it actually break?
Yeah yeah it broke it broke.
That's gone. Okay...
Plan B!
What is plan B?
It didn't even get halfway throughthe table.
Plan B!
Ready?
Wait! I'm ready!
Well we got a hole there!
Okay this is taking a while
likethis might be like too thick the table.
Well, 1-0 for me, let's continue.
This is gonna take the whole
night!
Okay so the second point of the match!
We have the whole night ahead of us!
Yeah it's going to take a while.
Maybe we do this to five points?
Drill is getting quite warm also.
Almost there!
There we have it!
Finally!
Okay one all.
One all after onehour.
Okay lets continue!
Come on guys!
I'll be the safety expert here.
It's like one millimeter or so.
Okay Emil this is a new tool once again.
This is plan C so far,
then we have plan D and plan E and..
50 more to go!
Time for plan D!
Plan E..?
Plan E is to wait for our construction manager Pekka.
Lets go to sleep.
Yesterday wasa complete disaster so today
it's time to take the plan E or F or whatever the planis.
Today we have also our construction manager Pekka.
Yeah let's continue from where we left!
That went.. that went.. that went
just a bit faster than yesterday.
Nice work!
We have a second hole and it only tookone minute!
Yesterday it took 25 minutes!
Yeah it seems to be working now!
Thanks Pekka!
So second hole on my side.
In the previous point you hit the forehand in thisspot
I don't want it here anymore.
I see I see.
You know guys now this feels fun again
like now we got this to work!
What was that? What was that?
I have been training!
I can see that!
It dropped like straight on to the GoPro.
Okay, the punishment!
You hit that previous forehand against me
I had to give you one back.
In the middle.
Now to think of it,
this wasn't really a wise position to put it because
now I can't serve.
Come on!
Nooooo! It hit the..
That was like weird bounce fromthe hole
so that's my point.
You're not allowed to touch the hole at all.
I'm covering my whole forehand area with this.
Haha sorry!
Even with the edge the last one!
Middle!
Noooo!
That was the latest hole.
I thought it was in a good spot.
I'm pretty sure Otto you'll start hitting my holes soon!
No the twiddle master didn't work!
6-4.
I'm more confident with my holes now.
I'm also quite confident with my holes.
Now it's starting to look a bit more scary for me.
No come on.
Middle is the space I don't want the balls coming.
Backhand and forehand it's okay,
middle not so good.
I have a tactical like servingplace still here.
I can still serve well.
Well I guess it's one morehole to me!
Yeah it's hole time!
I think I'll do the safe way, backhand serve.
Come on! Hit the..
Why does it never hit the hole?
Becauseyou lose the point if you hit those.
He's just the luckiest player alive.
You put the holes in the wrong spots.
You can only blame yourself.
Yeah this is the place.
So the score is 9-5.
Now now you started to hit them!
My holes are coming into play!
I missed the easiest one!
Lets put onea bit shorter one.
I'm catching up now!
That went straight into the hole!
Like it didn't even touch anything!
7-10.
That was a good roller!
But I think I lost the point.
I'm not getting in the way of that one!
I'm just lucky it didn't hit any holes.
So this time Otto won the (w)hole match.
Don't forget to hit subscribe!
Until next time!
Yeah I can't see I can't see anything!
Emil it's for your own safety!
I literally couldn't see anything from there!
It's not working with this mask.
They're not safety glasses in this case.
Should we end this video...?